qué tan convincente fue la defensa de
donald trump el uso de sólo tres de 16
horas para sus argumentos habla de
confianza en el destino del exmandatario
bueno realmente fue una defensa yo diría
muy débil
efectivamente como usted y se usaron muy
poco del tiempo que tenían asignados y
en realidad fue más que todo una
formalidad
haciendo referencia a que aquel esto es
simplemente una jugada del partido
demócrata para marginar y no hacer caso
a los 72 millones de votos que tuvo
donald trump y que además tratando de
hacer un argumento que jurídicamente y
políticamente no se ha sostenido y no se
sostiene y es que no puede ser juzgado
políticamente mediante la figura del
impeachment porque ya no está en la
presidencia algo que desde los inicios
de la creación del listado americano de
estado eeuu como lo demostraron los
demócratas con diversas citas de digamos
padres de la patria y diversos juristas
y políticos queda desmentido en realidad
los argumentos que porque como decía
esta mañana un comentarista en eeuu
podrían realmente incluso no haber hecho
ningún argumento tal que con lo que
están jugando es con que la mayor parte
de los senadores republicanos
es decidan no procesarlo o sea no votar
negativamente en el impeachment porque
básicamente están mirando a la base
electoral de chamba esa base electoral
de 72 millones de personas
bueno mariano y según eso cuál es el
futuro político que ustedes ve para
donald trump y además qué decir de la
conversación revelada con kevin mccarthy
habría alguna posibilidad de cambiar
este veredicto que usted predice
básicamente todos todos dan por hecho a
los analistas de que hoy él va a ser ya
de que no le van a procesar por el
impeachment otra cosa diferente aunque
también va a ser difícil sería que hay
diversos casos abiertos contra trump que
se podrían hablar
habrá que abrir por incitación a la
violencia y por otras cuestiones como
corrupción etcétera que eso los tiene
pendientes y de hecho gran parte se cree
y se considera y yo estoy de acuerdo que
gran parte de su de toda su
desesperación por quedarse en la casa
blanca ha estado orientado también a que
él y su núcleo más cercano como su hija
o el esposo de su hija heart expert cnr
kirchner teme en los juicios que se les
puedan abrir a continuación respecto del
futuro político es incierto o sea él
tiene el dinero que tiene una base
social que lo ha votado y puede seguir
de alguna manera impresionando a esa
base
puede seguir trabajando mediante redes
sociales y mientras sus campañas sobre
esa base social para que esa base social
opere a su vez sobre los senadores
republicanos que previsiblemente hoy van
a votar en su favor